ahora vamos a ponerle nombre a unas
aminas ligeramente más complicadas vamos
a empezar con este azul de aquí y lo
primero que hacemos Es ver cuál es la
cadena de carbonos más larga y esa es
esta Okay que tiene 1 dos 3 4 5 6 7 8
carbonos entonces podemos poner
octan no ponemos una o al final no
ponemos octano por que esta cadena tiene
varios grupos funcionales y tal vez
alguno de ellos tiene mayor prioridad
que el simple hecho de que esta cadena
de carbonos sea un alcano Entonces nada
más vamos a dejar el prefijo octan
Entonces vamos a ver estos grupos
funcionales Okay Tenemos aquí este que
es un nitrógeno con dos hidrógenos o sea
que es un grupo
amino
amino luego por aquí tenemos un anillo
bencénico pero los Anillos bencénicos
cuando los vemos como grupos funcionales
se llaman grupos
fenilosazona
y bueno eso es algo que simplemente nos
tenemos que aprender Okay no hay una
regla lógica que nos diga tal grupo
funcional tiene mayor prioridad que
tales otros simplemente los químicos se
pusieron de acuerdo Y decidieron Cuál
era el orden de prioridad ahora dentro
de ese orden de prioridad los grupos
hidroxilos tienen mayor prioridad tanto
que el grupo fenilo como que el grupo
amino y entonces a la hora de ponerle
nombre a esta molécula en lugar de decir
que tiene un grupo hidróxilo decimos que
esta molécula es un alcohol y la
terminación de los alcoholes es
ol Entonces al nombre de la cadena más
larga de carbonos que tenemos en esta
molécula Le ponemos el sufijo de los
alcoholes que es
ol Y entonces numeramos los carbonos de
esta cadena haciendo que el grupo
hidróxilo sea el que tiene el carbono
con el menor número Así es que tenemos
que empezar por aquí Este es el carbono
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 y entonces como el
grupo hidroxilo está en el carbono
número tres movemos la terminación un
poquito para acá y indicamos justo antes
de la terminación ol entre iones el
número de carbono en el que se encuentra
el grupo hidroxid kilo Okay entonces
esta molécula es un octan 3 all pero
todavía nos falta indicar estos otros
dos grupos funcionales y bueno si este
no fuera el grupo funcional de mayor
prioridad Por ejemplo si hubiera un
grupo tiol entonces en lugar de poner la
terminación ol pondríamos por aquí
adelante tres hidroxi y luego ya octan
con alguna otra terminación pero bueno
como tenemos a un grupo fenil en el
carbono c entonces lo que tenemos es un
c
fenil y luego como tenemos un grupo
amino en el carbono ocho Entonces
tenemos un ocho amino y la palabra amino
empieza con a mientras que la palabra
fenil empieza con f y a va antes que f
en el abecedario Entonces vamos a
indicar a este grupo Antes de indicar a
este y lo que nos queda al final es es
ocho amino
amino cinco
fenil cinco fenil fenil y ahora sí octan
tresol
octan tres ol y listo así se llama esta
molécula que por cierto aunque tenga la
terminación ol de los alcoholes también
es un compuesto aromático porque tiene
un anillo bencénico y tambén es una
amina porque tiene un grupo amino y
claro también es un alcohol porque tiene
un grupo hidróxilo Pero bueno ahora
vamos a ponerle nombre a esta otra
molécula lo primero que hacemos Es
Buscar la cadena de carbonos más larga
que encontremos y en esta molécula esa
es este anillo bencénico cierto y
después nos fijamos en los grupos
funcionales yo digo que empecemos por el
grupo funcional más raro que tenemos
aquí Bueno no el más raro pero uno que
no hemos visto todavía que es este grupo
funcional de aquí Este es un grupo Nitro
Nitro y es muy explosivo Okay
seguramente voy a hacer un video acerca
de trinitroglicerina y TNT que como
sabes son explosivos muy famosos y bueno
como no son tan comunes ni tienen mucho
tiempo en la historia de la química los
grupos Nitro tienen muy poca prioridad
Así es que casi nunca Bueno de hecho
nunca se utilizan para determinar la
terminación de la cadena de los carbonos
Okay como lo hicimos aquí con el alcohol
y también tenemos un grupo funcional
halógeno Tenemos aquí un bromo y una
amina Okay
amina
y bromo y bueno de estos tres grupos
funcionales
el grupo con mayor prioridad es la amina
Y entonces numeramos a los carbonos de
este benzeno desde aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 y
todos nos podemos sentir muy tentados a
decir que esta molécula se llama tres
bromo cu Nitro bencenamina pero no
resulta que cuando una mina se enlaza
con un benceno o sea exactamente lo que
tenemos aquí esto tiene un nombre
especial okay si tenemos un anillo
bencénico que se encuentra enlazado con
nh2 que es la amina más sencilla una
amina primaria y que es justo lo que
tenemos aquí entonces a todo esto junto
le llamamos
anilina
Ani Lina y como este es el grupo
funcional de mayor prioridad entonces
Este es el nombre base así como aquí
teníamos a octan 3 sol aquí lo que
tenemos es anilina
anilina y Bueno aquí numeramos muy bien
al benceno poniendo un uno donde se
encuentra el grupo funcional amina que
es el de mayor prioridad y siguiendo la
numeración de tal forma que nos
encontremos con otro grupo funcional lo
antes posible Entonces lo único que nos
falta es indicar que tenemos un bromo en
el tercer carbono y un grupo Nitro en el
cuarto carbono el bromo va antes que el
Nitro tomando en cuenta una ordenación
alfabética Y entonces lo ponemos primero
en el nombre así es que tenemos tres
bromo bromo y vamos a necesitar más
espacio y luego tenemos cuatro Nitro
cuatro Nitro anilina y listo tres bromo
cu nitro anilina y ya
terminamos